Here's what gensequence looks like.
We have a recursive base case that says, if there are no numbers that we're looking for,
we can't generate anything of those lengths, and so return the empty set.
Then we say the xmatches we get by applying x to any number up to the maximum of Ns,
including the maximum of Ns,
but then we got to do some computation to figure out what can be the allowable sizes
for y, and we do that by saying, let's take all the possible values that came back
from the xmatches and then for each of those values and for each of the original values
for the lengths that we're looking for, subtract those off
and say, total is going to be one of the things we got from x
and one of the things we got from y, that better add up to one of the things in Ns.
Then we call y with that set of possible ends for y and then we do the same thing
that we were going to do before.
We go through those matches, but this is going to be with a reduced set of possibilities
and count those up,
and now, the thing that makes it all work is this optional argument here,
saying the number that we're going to start at for the possible sizes, for x
in the default case, that's 0, and so we start the range at 0.
But in the case where we're calling from +, we're going to set that to 1.
Let's see what that looks like.
Here's the constructors, the compilers for sequence and plus.
For a regular sequence, there is no constraint on this start for x.
X can be any size up to the maximum of the N's.
But for plus, we're going to always ask that the x part have a length of at least 1,
and then the y part will be whatever is left over.
That's how we break the recursion, and we make sure that genseq will always terminate.
Now this language generation program is a little bit complex.
So I wanted to make sure that I wrote a test suite for it to test the generation.
So here I've just defined some helper functions
and then wrote a whole bunch of statements here.
If we check one of 'ab' and limit that to size 2,
that should be equal to this set.
It's gone off the page. Let's put it back where it belongs.
One element of size 0, 2 elements of size 1, and 4 elements of size 2,
just what you would expect.
Here are sequences of a star, b star, c star of size exactly 4.
Here they are and so on and so on.
We've made all these tests.
I should probably make more than these, but this will give you some confidence
that the program is doing the right thing
if it passes at least this minimal test suite.